[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
howie roseman the executive vice
president and general manager
of the eagles howie my f by the way
thanks for coming on the show but my
first question before i even get to the
draft stuff do you have anything to do
with the food
over there because i was there in philly
for people don't know
at the eagles cafeteria i was working
the draft for the eagles for their
eagles.com and their food is so good
it is so good exactly what to say to me
ross like i am obsessed with the food
that we have for draft weekend to the
extent that like we're meetings and then
you know katie who's been with me 20
years she's like have you seen the menu
i'm like i'm sure the menu is great
she's like can you please look at the
menu because i know it's gonna you
become friday or saturday and you're
gonna care and you're gonna say i didn't
see the menu so it is so important to me
about the quality of food that we have
it's such a passion of mine
it's unbelievable i'm so glad you reckon
thank you thank you for recognizing it i
mean i had an omelette i had a smoothie
i had fruit what's it called like asi
eyeball or asi assaye i don't even know
what it is
i mean howie i i think i tweeted during
the weekend that i would come out of
retirement just to be able to eat what
you guys get to eat every day it's
unreal now that's a different menu than
we give the players now i just want to
be clear you know like we can't do that
and and then we get some local
restaurants here favorites you know it's
unbelievable it's an unbelievable
weekend in fact you know my wife said
yesterday you know what do you want a
last sunday night dinner and you know
anything you want you're done with the
draft and um like you know our job's
over like i'm going on vacation
but um but i was like you know what like
the last three i don't even know like i
freaking killed it the last three days
you know
so i'm glad you recognized all right so
speaking of exciting so i'm there and it
felt like howie
the trade up from 15 to 13 to get jordan
davis
and then the aj brown trade with the
18th overall pick in my mind
that all happened in like five ten
minutes i know it was probably longer
than that but it felt like five ten
minutes how does that happen like when
did you start to lay the groundwork and
when did you have a pretty good idea
that that was going to happen
well to the credit of the titans and
j-rob john robinson tremendous general
manager of the tennessee titans um you
know the r-trade with them was done um
but at the same time you know we weren't
gonna gonna make a trade with a first
round pick and and have a guy for one
year left on this deal so we had to
do an extension um toward andy um aj's
agent we've done a lot of deals with
obviously jimmy sexton long time
relationship with him
um so we just had to do it but it wasn't
done so we're we're kind of
you know kind of dealing with the fact
that we have two picks
and we had to make sure that first pick
was right because really that's the
anchor that's the anchor like that first
pick in the draft and
shoot i'm not so sure jordan davis can't
handle an anchor like we have the pen
relays this week you know
man that guy's free so um so we have to
do that and then at the same time like
we don't have the deal done and so um
gotta go and try to finish that deal
because you know you want to be fair to
john robinson you know like it's kind of
like am i picking 18th am i you know
what what's going on here
um and at the same time you know philly
you know philly ross you know it and
just imagine that like you know we can't
get a deal with aj and all of a sudden
three days later it's reported like we
can't get a deal we had aj brown we
couldn't get him
boy that wouldn't be good that wouldn't
be good so you know there weren't many
people who knew about this
and so a part of it was like um
we also wanted to have a competitive
advantage of no one knowing what we were
trying to do in the first round so
nobody trade up in front of us and get
one of the players if we had a receiver
that probably changes the approach for
teams of our first pick and you know the
same thing with j-rock j rob wanted to
make sure he got uh what he he wanted so
we were like we're gonna not tell anyone
except obviously you know
jeffrey knows nick knows and then when
we're on the clock at 18 we're just
going to announce this trade and then
it's going to come out after that so
what was cool about it is we we did the
deal i think we were done with the deal
uh either pick 14 or 15. um
and
um and then like still the people in our
draft room didn't know
what was going on and then we brought
everyone in you know around the pocket
18 and i'm sure people had favorites who
were going to pick there and
and basically said hey we traded the
pick and you know i think people at this
point that we traded the pick and i was
like now we got aj brown here we go
so so that's interesting so you had the
trade
parameters worked out with the titans
but you were literally on the clock
with aj brown's agent because if you
don't get him signed to a contract or
agreed to
by the 18th pick you wouldn't have done
the trade so that that's got to be about
as as
intense of a negotiations because
usually you have time for any kind of
contract negotiation you're talking like
a span of minutes deadline to get a big
contract done now we are dealing with it
the whole day so it wasn't like that was
the you know where we're starting it
when the draft starts we're dealing with
it but yeah we had work to do and credit
to everyone involved
yeah but you had a deadline you had to
get it done um you also second year in a
row you moved up a couple spots
to draft the guy you really wanted last
year devonta smith who had a tremendous
rookie year this year was for jordan
davis
walk us through those trades too you
talk about the parameters with the
texans i'm assuming before the draft and
you just kind of have intel or you have
a gut feeling or just there's a decent
chance that the team in front of you
might like the same guy
well you know obviously tremendous
respect for the baltimore ravens and uh
they got a tremendous player i think for
us it was just it was important for us
that we got this player this fit it just
made sense for our team
and um how we wanted to build it and so
uh we just didn't want to take the risk
you know and i'm sure they they they're
static about the player they got is a
great player and great person
um so i i don't want to say i knew what
they were doing because you know eric
ozzie uh coach harps i mean those guys
are really good at what they do i think
for us it was just ensuring we got the
right player for the philadelphia eagles
so let's talk about jordan davis um i
love the guy i was trying to get him to
win the heisman last year during the
season
i guess the one critique i think is
interesting about him howie is the lack
of you know pass rush stats and pass
rush production but what's funny to me
about that i guess is that's the same
thing people are saying about trayvon
walker who was the number one pick in
the draft it's the same thing they're
saying about
wyatt who was a first round pick and
looking at the stats for georgia last
year it almost feels like your third
round pick nicolby dean with six and a
half sec like there's only so many stats
to go around all right well and i think
also you know you got to look at what
they're asking to do there right for
sure you also have to look at at the
fact that and you know uh our scouts our
analytics group like they all they cause
these are the conversation and draft
rooms like convince me that i shouldn't
be worried about this you know because
you see it in his body i mean you see
him as a nose one-on-one with the center
and you see
the pushback you see him looping on
stunts and you see he's got closing
speed and i think one of the great
points was like you know this team
won a lot of games by a lot of points
and so like they have a lot of five star
guys is he playing in the fourth quarter
when all due respect they're beating
georgia southern by 40 points right like
is that a situation where like you know
he's going and he's just you know
they're winning by two touchdowns in the
fourth quarter he's just russian you
know you don't see that as much and and
i think the same thing like he he had a
a sack
against alabama that was called back
there was a penalty that doesn't count
no does it change now when he's got
three and a half sacks or four stacks so
i think for us we knew what was in his
body we knew what kind of player he
could be i mean this is a guy even
saying all that you know all the awards
it was he top ten in the heisman voting
right won the allen trophy like we're
not talking about a guy who didn't who
wasn't productive helped you know the
number one ranked defense in the country
so
um we understand all that and obviously
listen if this guy had eight sacks would
he be anywhere near the 13th pick in the
draft ross no way i mean the guy's going
in the top five well that's what i was
gonna say if georgia had him out there
for more obvious passing downs he's a
top five pick and you guys don't have a
chance to get him
in the first place uh i mentioned the
third round pick nicolby dean you know
there's a lot of comments that came out
as he was falling in the draft
about his health i guess can you just
walk us through the process you know i
guess different teams doctors have
different opinions what is the process
for evaluating guys grading their health
and what were you told
well i think for the first thing is
that's a huge part of why we go to india
in the combine and there are guys who go
and have more information and and then
teams
they share medical information you know
that doesn't mean everyone's got the
same opinion but they share hey we got
more risk we got less risk
and our docs do a great job of that and
then you have a medical meeting about a
week before the draft um you know some
teams kind of maybe do it earlier
sometimes some teams maybe later but and
and we basically say
this is where we're at this is where we
are on these guys and you know we're
there we're gonna put them on the board
or not you know if this is this is a
foul we're not gonna put the kid on the
board and so you know coming out of that
medical meeting i i didn't think the
issue with the kobe was the medical i
thought the issue in the kobe was like
if we don't take him in in the top 20
are we getting this guy probably not
right he's probably gone and so
when we got into friday you know you
have these conversations with your docs
and and you basically say hey you're a
couple of guys that we're looking at at
51. the kobe's there and there and you
know they kind of we walked us through
it and
um at the end of the day we decided to
take cam only because
stubbornly convicted about holland
d-line right like
it was kind of the same but that's just
that's how we roll here you know and
it's like
um
you got to stand for something and and
that's what we want to stand for and so
we took cam but those are the two guys
and i'm not gonna lie i'm sure a bunch
of our scouts were you know love cam but
also like man that's the colby dean and
so then you know it's kind of like uh
and at that time you're saying hey this
guy's falling you guys good and yeah
we're good
and then he's falling more and then it
almost becomes like
we must be missing something here you
know like we must so there's probably
between our pick the first 10 picks are
just like he's going you know so you
don't even worry about it you're so far
away um but as we got about 15 picks
away like i'm superstitious so i didn't
want to jinx it like i didn't want it
because i really wasn't anticipating him
be there and i think
um as we got closer i'm like are we sure
like i i think i like three times i call
are we sure like this this is how he if
he's on this team he'll be out there
rookie mini cam next week you know and
so then it's just like um
let's take the kobe dean like right like
it doesn't matter like it was funny
because we got a
a few trade calls at that point and and
obviously we didn't have a lot of volume
in this draft based on the trades we did
in the first round and we started with
10 picks and definitely gonna end up
with 10 pigs but it's like we we
actually got our
amazingly good offers in the third round
and some of those trades ended up
happening so you can look at them but um
it was like
man we can't mess around i mean colby
dean it's like is there a more
philadelphia eagle than nicole dean
love it howie really appreciate the time
thank you so much for coming on the show
appreciate you having me have a great
day yeah you too there he is howie
roseman the eagles executive vice
president and general manager they had
one of the more eventful drafts that's
for sure